das finale der cyber security challenge
2020 geht am mittwoch in ganz österreich
über die bühne haben sich die teilnehmer
vergangener jahre noch physisch
getroffen findet das finale dieses mal
corona bedingt nur mehr im internet
statt alle teilnehmer laden sich die
aufgaben von einer speziellen plattform
herunter von dem sogenannten hacking lab
es wären im hecklinger übungen verfügbar
gestellt unterschiedlicher schwierigkeit
sei es von crypto bereich im kritischen
bereich
ein knacken von passwörtern und
ähnliches aufgaben die von den meist
jugendlichen teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmern gelöst werden müssen wir
haben es hier wirklich mit den besten
österreichs zu tun und ich bin immer
wieder fasziniert so viel wie an
aufgaben herangehen und wie wir das
lösen und was die in ihren jungen jahren
schon alles im kasten unter den besten
seines jahrgangs war florian bogen hat
er hat sich mittlerweile mit einem
startup selbstständig gemacht also über
die cyber security aus beton mein erstes
construction tester bekommen
ob dort meine erfahrungen sammeln können
und ich sagte okay eigentlich möchte
etwas anderes machen als alle anderen
und vor drei jahren habe mit zehn meter
breite security selbstständig gemacht
und besucher aktuelle songs und damit
ein mann oder gerne auch frau der cyber
defense markt gilt als eine der größten
wachstumsbranchen überhaupt cyber
defence cyber security in mannigfaltiger
ausprägung wir haben es die letzten
jahre auch mit angriffen zu tun die vor
zehn jahren so nicht denkbar waren dass
österreich aufholbedarf in dieser
branche hat bestreitet niemand mit der
cyber defense challenge sei man aber auf
dem richtigen weg ich glaube die
veranstaltung die es gibt ist ist die
beste den man sich vorstellen kann also
ich würde dort keine veranstaltungen
mehr wünschen oder vorstellen natürlich
kann der veranstaltung noch mehr präsenz
und noch mehr aufmerksamkeit geben finde
durchaus sinnvoll findet notwendig und
wir machen hier einiges dass das dass
das passiert oder die beste propaganda
ist immer noch word of mouse und und und
so kommuniziert man immer am besten
und ich glaube das kann gar nicht genug
und talente geben und für genug
förderung von talenten geben in allen
bereichen und natürlich mein interesse
der geräte bereich absolut nicht nur
seit bundesministern amtes sondern das
zieht sich schon über jahre das im
bereich der selber einiges an
aufholbedarf notwendig ist ich denke wir
sind jetzt auf einem guten weg